all right uh james bond has been
acquired by
jeff bezos i mean
this is the no-brainer acquisition isn't
it 9 billion or so
james bond has made like 10 billion
historically like it's just a no-brainer
that they would buy this
right shocking that those geniuses at
amazon negotiated a really nice m
a deal i mean i i've never heard of them
uh
having a very favorable terms
acquisition before this is brand new
news
of course it's not the uh they are
notoriously unbelievable negotiators
um and they they definitely found a way
to i believe
get uh get this asset on super
opportunities it's amazing it hasn't
been picked up yet
the mgm has been around the block so
many times back when
i was a media investment banker in new
york right after
uh right out of undergrad and mgm this
was in 2007 2008 mgm was getting chopped
around all the time
then i can't believe a major media
company hadn't
picked it up yet well i mean 8.45
billion
um is the official price and
if you just look at james bond i was
thinking about this and i just did some
google searches 27 films over 58 years
okay so this is a
six decade franchise star wars was 77 so
you had the 70s 80s 90s
arts 2010 so that also is i guess about
telling us when you went on our pod that
uh you had like pirated the empire
strikes back or something yeah that was
my original business was jason's hot
tapes
i had started um a my first business was
jason's hot tapes and i literally had a
bootleg copy the empire strikes back and
i just kept bootlegging it worse and
worse you could barely watch it
but you know uh some guy owed my dad
money he lost in poker or backgammon and
in exchange these guys at like one of
the theaters in bensonhurst would set up
10 vhs tapes and they would start the
movie and they would literally run
and hit the record button right down the
line and then take the tapes out
run the movie again and they would just
make you know
in one day because they had stolen they
literally stole off a truck a copy of
the empire strikes back
nobody knows where that tape was and
there were all kinds of scams like this
i mean the other one we were doing was i
had met a guy
from one of my friends in fifth grade
sixth grade and
um then he wanted copies of like chess
master and then when we were like in
eighth or ninth grade we started
pirating chess master for pc
and he would give us like a dollar so we
would go steal
floppy disk which cost three dollars
from
like a store we'd literally steal and
then we would make copies of this
and we take the five year discount and
then actually we negotiated more like
five dollars because i think chestnuts
was 50.
so we'd give it to five he would sell it
for ten and we would just sit there and
every time the disc would come out of
the machine
you know in 20 minutes of copying it
we'd be like well there's five bucks
well there's five bucks well there's
five bucks it was like we're counting
out
five and a quarter inch floppies but
enough of my life of crime
i literally could have been lex luthor
um if if i had pursued that path
thank the lord the internet happened and
i had a place to put this but
uh worldwide box office um if you
adjusted for inflation 14 billion
the last four films with daniel craig
who i think is kind of the best
bond ever i don't well we'll rate bonds
in a second 2.9 billion box office
um and it's currently the fourth highest
grossing franchise worldwide
the marvel cinematic universe 22 billion
good
skyfall alone did over a billion one in
revenue and it only cost 150 million to
make i mean these are
cash cows i mean and i don't know how
they i mean daniel craig is like i'm
getting old like
and they just like 150 million 300 i
think he's getting
i left my research just to look it up
but i thought he got 150 million for the
last two films or 300 million i can't
remember it was
for some reason 150 and he was like i am
out i hate this role
and when i saw him say that publicly i'm
like he's good for two more
like that's the move on the way
negotiating up that's what he's doing
yes
when you say i am done with this i hate
this character
that means you got two left right
because you're you're poisoning the well
but you know you're kind of like there
isn't you're open to getting paid
exactly like you know like when robert
downey jr says i hate iron man
he's doing four more that's the
basically how it goes
uh marvel cinematic universe has done 22
billion across like 8 000 movies at this
point star wars 10 billion
harry potter uh sadly i know you guys
love this
you millennials but that piece of
garbage can really went off the deep end
like did she i mean i don't know
oh god david okay we can't go there
sure do we want to get into uh no women
fighting for women's rights against
trans people
hmm three white guys should we go there
okay yeah let's not go there
okay let's not go let's stay in our lane
don't want to talk about feminism and
trans rights uh okay great let's stick
on bond something we know
who's the best bond let's just start
there give me your sean connery
how on earth could everybody not say
sean daniel quite close too but
come on i respect i respect that
david i agree i've got such a soft spot
for pierce brosnan for two reasons
though just because that's what i grew
up with
and two well he did like two of them
right gold now
64 is the
number one bond related media property
in history i put so many thousands of
hours so literally your bond decision
is based upon the guy who they blocked
from doing the role
and he did like one great video game one
of the best video games of all time
okay he the equality argue is
is infinitely higher than any individual
bond movie
what you're about you're so out of your
mind also
is definitively the worst bond no doubt
it's all okay everybody there it is the
acquired podcast has ended
the breaking news they've broken up i'm
going to take one of them for
one of them is going to the all in pod
as an alternate and one of them is going
to co-host this reagan startup that's
the end of the podcast
you're all getting refunds on your pro
accounts all right let me correct you
guys now when i was growing up
my first bond was roger roger moore so
i believed like lauren michael says
from snl whichever cast you grew up on
is your favorite cast just like whatever
album you grow up on a period of music
is your
the best music ever i grew up on roger
moore and i have a sp
soft spot for him but when i look back
on it historically
he was suave but he wasn't dark
and then i looked at sean connery and he
was suave
and i think more masculine and stronger
as a bond oh and he could fight
and he could fight connor he would he
was a scound and he was a scoundrel so
he had a little bit more of that but he
wasn't dark
he wasn't super dark and then you have
daniel badass like
he said it's hard to be more badass with
a smile right like he would push you
into a
pool of sharks and wink and it but you
know he wasn't going to shoot you in the
back
or the stomach and watch you bleed out
and that's why
i have come to the conclusion that the
best bond the most accurate bond is
daniel craig
because he is troubled he is dark in the
same way i look at batman's today where
i
felt for a period of time that um
you know like in terms of casting you've
got to think the dark knight
is the best batman of the series but
when you look back on the batman that um
oh what's his name gosh why is it not
coming to me
that was the one i grew up michael
keaton michael keaton is an
infant is just an incredible actor
incredible actor uh
and his batman could have been the best
batman i believe
if they had made the series darker but
when they made it sort of comic booky
with jack nichols
it was a little too campy so i have to
go with
obviously the dark knight series uh it's
so weird you're not
you're not even talking about ben
affleck actually you know
did you guys see the snyder cut i mean
yeah it was even worse than the original
no you're crazy oh my god no the 4x3
thing really bothered me that was weird
that i couldn't shake that was very
weird the story was better though you're
right
the story was so much better the
character development was so much better
the flash was so much better cyborg was
so much better
it just goes to show is like founder
authority versus a hired gun ceo like
you really felt that kind of switch so
for amazon this is just another
awesome acquisition in the mold of their
whole foods like
how did somebody else not get this
yeah it's old ip right i was looking at
the names of a lot of these films it's
bond
it's raging bull it's like clams
yeah yeah like none of this is new so it
is effectively i think it's two things
it's one hey we finally have a bat
catalog
in amazon prime video that's not our
originals that we
own outright that we're not borrowing
and competing every year to license and
fighting netflix that sort of thing but
then it's also
we are going to and i know this was a
sticking point in the deal so i'm
curious to see where it lands
we are going to do what disney did with
marvel on disney plus and do a zillion
shows
we are going to start repurposing the
bond ip the
um you know all of this different
historically classic ip
rocky and figure out things to do in uh
like brand new
things to do with vip in absolutely if
you look they own stargate and robocop
and if you think about those two
franchises those would be amazing series
to do a stargate series again because
stargate was a great movie and a great
series
robocop incredible ip just think about
the world building you could do in
robocop alone that would be an amazing
vehicle
for a series and i just want to give a
shout out here to dredd i don't know if
you guys saw the dread film
from i think it was 2009 or something
d-r-e-d-d
um this film is such a good dark science
fiction film and they're
they've been talking about the 2020 film
dread
uh with carl urbain becoming a
serious did you either of you happen to
see this dread 2012 no
is it watch this
it is so the judge did was comic bookie
this is the dark knight version of dread
in other words
it looks like the dark knight when you
see this film it is so good it has the
woman liliana
what's her name from uh lena heady
from um game of thrones in it as the
villain
it is amazing it is like dark science
fiction
thank me later to the audience um
the uh well there's also there's such an
easy win here like
those are like uh the next wins that
amazon can i'm sure capable of doing
the easy win here is like the the uh
operations of the bond franchise have
been so screwed up like
these movies come out so slowly amazon's
gonna be able to clean that up
pump out a movie every two two and a
half years yeah easy win
also just think about ten out of craig
on amazon's schedule yeah well
uh also think about um you know with an
unlimited budget
and you think about that world you know
we know double07
but they've never really told the
stories of any of the other bonds and i
know this would be sack religious i
guess
but you know they've been talking about
this controversy of oh what if bond was
a different
wasn't a white guy right basically like
well why not tell the story
about five or six agents you know 007
will not be a white guy in this upcoming
movie
uh own the new one do they did they cast
that yet or no
it it yeah so daniel craig is still
james bond but there is a
double-oh-seven who
is not oh right so they are already
preparing the audience because he's
retired or something and
she's now taking off
talking about that i don't remember my i
read the story like six months ago
yeah so anyway they've been talking
about 07 being played by a woman
or a different person a different you
know whatever
uh a non-white english male and so i
think that's gonna be idris elba for
years and years and years and that would
have been so awesome
yeah i mean why not tell the story of
the other dublo agents like if you think
about world building
you know you think about lord of the
rings you think about what they did with
game of thrones like
it need not be about o seven you could
create a whole world here
of the other agents and other jobs they
were doing
right you could do mi6 and you could do
a series mi6
that then dovetails and explain and
builds fabric between all the movies so
imagine between moonraker
you know and skyfall and and all these
things
they could go back and forth to the 80s
to the 70s and do fan
service between all the different bonds
yeah that one will be such an
interesting dance because
unlike uh marvel cinematic universe or
a star wars where they really do
have an answer for everything a lot of
it's very hand wavy in bond where
they're like oh well it's always in the
present
and that's why the technology always
sort of evolves and like
no actually all the bonds all these
different actors they're the same person
and they've always been the same age and
and like there's conflicts all over the
place and i
i it would be an interesting job to be
the person who is in charge of
figuring out how to make this into a
proper universe and create continuity
with all the hand waving that they've
done in the past
uh interesting so there is
a term for this is it recon or weak ret
converts conformity yeah something like
that
uh retcon noun a piece of new
information that imposes a different
interpretation on previously described
events typically used to facilitate a
dramatic plot shift
or account for an inconsistency revise
an aspect of fictional work
retrospectively typically to introduce a
new piece of information that opposes a
different interpretation
right like actually i think that there
was like some
reticle disney did this with star wars
they they
decided that they named a certain set of
of art as
canon and there was non-canon and like
if you were non-canon then
it's not part of the story well and
remember the the criticism of star wars
was like oh they built the death star
and they left a hole in it that could
blow up the whole thing like that's the
stupidest thing ever these are the
smartest engineers they can make a
planet-sized
weapon and they left a hole in it's like
no
an engineer who was being who has
secretly
built this flaw and gave it to his
daughter so
that whole thing with um what's the
movie
rogue one rogue one is literally the
best retcon
ever yeah yeah they literally retconned
the one floor in star wars such a
congratulations to the star wars i mean
i think
of of my favorite star wars movie is is
that's
got to be up there for me i mean just
the darth vader scene at the end
oh my god
i literally i think that was the most
emotional i felt that year absolutely
wow i mean
if darth vader was your biggest
emotional moment for the year
he's like actually i'll back that up
this is great
david david what was your biggest
emotional moment of the year was it like
a
spongebob squarepants moment or was it
like
what was it for you oh yeah i have to i
don't think about that i don't know but
uh
but the emotion i was feeling the other
day was just i'm so sad and disappointed
at how bad episode nine
was you guys garbage
you guys want to know the best tweet of
my life best twitter moment in 11 years
on the platform or whatever 15 years
i said they should retcon the entire
post trilogy get rid of 789
and redo it with mark hamill
and show the story of the building of
the jedi temple and give people what
they want
and mark hamill liked it oh
wow i am not kidding you're making a
case
for a career transition into the into
that there you go there you go
absolutely i was born to be a studio
head
absolutely get me a humidor with cigars
in it i will throw people out of my
amazon might be like
i want somebody to run mgm i'll throw
i'll throw a macbook out the window i'll
do whatever i'll drive
my car up on the sidewalk on a bush and
park it there i don't care
i'll be a studio head yeah let's go
these things all happen in entourage i
think so yeah
i would be a great studio head i would
make absolutely flippant decisions
and
silicon valley version of entourage oh
my god with the best deals that's
hilarious
how good would that be okay yeah calling
hbo
if they want to wreck up they want to
create a series based on my insane life
and punch it up three levels
ari emanuel go ahead into our gold
character
like but uh so imagine that though see i
think
that that's actually what's happening if
you remember at the end of
the mandalorian you had luke skywalker
show up and take grog spoiler alert
and did you notice he was a fast jedi at
that point
do you notice the speed he had was
similar to anakin skywalker and obi-wan
in the prequels he was a fast jedi right
so the jedi and star wars were all slow
because they were old and they had you
know darth vader was missing three limbs
and was on life support obi-wan was 80
years old
they were slow jedi and luke was a new
jedi so he barely knew how to use his
lightsaber she watched those lightsaber
battles and it looks ridiculous
but when you go to the prequels you
remember how fast they are and they're
fighting drones that are showing up
like 16 times to make one saber strike
then you have the new series and all of
a sudden they're fast again
that's because luke skywalker became
fast luke skywalker
becomes like a real fast jedi gets grogu
and then
princess leia becomes a jedi and then
you just create an entirely new story
and throw away seven eight nine i'm i'm
with you just because
it was so bad i liked i liked eight
though what did you think of eight
i you know i tried to like it i tried to
like it
i just don't like when people are trying
to
do something other than tell a great
story
with great characters and aesthetics and
dialogue and performance in movies
when they try to lecture you through the
story
i it breaks me out of the story
i'm like please don't lecture me about
being woke in the middle of star wars
like
i get that all day long on twitter i'm
not at the movies
for you to scream at me like hysterical
libs on twitter or
troll me like the right right like
that's what they did with that movie
they're like
by the way here are some other
characters who haven't been represented
before and i'm like i get it
yes i understand star wars was made at a
time when it was like
only white people i got it now you're
making it and it's just like a little
bit of tedious
i did i really liked it and and and and
this the
the direction they took the story in
because of that made no sense
like the entire 25-minute segment on the
vegas planet
to just show that those wealthy people
were financing the war
you're like yeah i get it yes you could
have done that in a
one or two passing lines the thing
though for me that i really liked about
it though was the the ray is nobody
uh thing like i thought that was great
yeah i the only thing i don't like about
rey is nobody is that they had faked us
into thinking
she's obi-wan's child she's luke's child
she's
the emperor she's a clone i mean
they didn't actually know right i mean
that this shows the dysfunction that was
going on in the organization at that
point
my beef with the final trilogy is that
it didn't have one single director
i actually would have been fine if it
was jj all the way through the film
i didn't like was eight i actually liked
nine because if you're gonna do seven
and nine in that style
you're basically saying we're doing kind
of a fun fan
service reboot of star wars with great
modern technology
it's going to feel a lot like the
original there's going to be you know
it's not going to feel groundbreaking
ryan johnson is a groundbreaking
director he's artistic
he is making choices yeah yeah and so
having that sandwiched in between jj
movies that were really trying to just
preserve what george had created created
this this like
just ugly discontinuity and i wish they
had had just committed to someone early
on